[Música]
bem-vindo à nossa nova vida
uma vida de máscaras distância social medo
viagens interrompidas
e casas decentes você se lembra
da primeira vez em que pensou que o
mundo
parou você se lembra quando nossas vidas e nossa
economia
foram interrompidas por esse minúsculo
microscópico
e  bug muito assustador bem,
lembro-me claramente de uma chamada que recebi
tarde da noite no dia
26 de janeiro deste ano federico as
coisas aqui são perigosas sinto muito que
ninguém está embarcando no voo hoje à noite
que era meu gerente de delegação da china
eu e minha equipe trabalhamos  tão difícil em
perfilar invasores lá e
startups de inovação
e agora um vírus estava parando tudo
dois dias depois eu estava apagando as
luzes de outra edição bem-sucedida da
plataforma de aviação de investimento
sem a china é claro, mas
conseguimos ingressos com milhões e
milhões de dólares de  investimento
em um pipeline e tudo foi ótimo
nos sentimos empolgados
não podíamos imaginar o que estava prestes a
acontecer na verdade
muito poucos fizeram alguns d  ays depois o mundo
parou a
aviação e o turismo sofreu o
maior nocaute da sua história
e toda a humanidade está agora a viver da
pior crise monetária e económica
dá para sentir que é real
não é mas
estamos todos aqui com a missão de partilhar
ideias vale a pena  espalhando
ideias que podem mudar o mundo estou
animado,
você deve estar animado esta é a nossa grande
oportunidade de ser trabalhadores da linha de frente
é hora de arregaçar as mangas e começar a
trazer a economia de volta
porque somos todos responsáveis e acred
te em mim isso
stá afetando a todos
nós  posso adivinhar que você está pensando que não estou
trabalhando no setor
bem, acho que você está errado porque de
acordo com a organização mundial de turismo
as
chegadas de turismo diminuíram entre
58 a 78
em média globalmente e alguns aeroportos 90
outros estão fechados 100  a 120 milhões de
empregos estão em risco ou serão perdidos
a organização mundial do comércio estimou que
80 bilhões de dólares de receita
apenas no mês de março foram perdidos
globalmente
eles simplesmente pararam de fazer isso  e matemática então
espere espere espere
então se nós podemos ter 100 milhões de empregos diretos
perdidos quanto é isso traduzido em
empregos indiretos
você sabe que é claro que ele não
ninguém faz milhões aqui bilhões lá
organizações políticos economias
mídia todos eles referem
que o turismo é  um dos setores mais afetados
durante a pandemia essa é a
frase de efeito
quase e se eu te dissesse que o turismo é de
longe o setor mais afetado porque o
turismo é muito mais do
que viajantes aviação turismo eventos
turismo saudades de todos nós turismo gera
investimentos verticais quase
desconhecido quero dizer podemos sentir não podemos
entender
isso gera gastos indiretos e
fluxos de investimento que escapam ao nosso
conhecimento e relatórios de especialistas
é por isso que estamos no escuro
você vê os viajantes gerarem esse
rio invisível de dinheiro crucial para a sobrevivência de
milhões e milhões de famílias
pequenas e médias empresas em todo o mundo
e
não estamos entendendo a real
importância desta seita  ou,
por exemplo, julgá-lo como um pai pobre
de um
produto interno bruto nacional de qualquer
país e
, portanto, por correspondência de consequência,
propor
fluxos de investimento proporcionais, você pode
sugerir um país cuja indústria do turismo
é importante, digamos, acima de
5% do PIB, que tem um muito forte
e
estratégia estratégica para o turismo para os
próximos 10 a 20
anos é hora de entender por que alguns
destinos vão se recuperar muito rápido
enquanto outros ficarão congelados ou até
desaparecerão
nos próximos anos, então por que alguns
destinos de viagem terão sucesso
e outros falharão durante o café 19
uma vez trabalhei para um grupo de hospitalidade
que era dono de
um dos melhores eventos quando é a hora se
não o melhor acho que
ninguém poderia nos vencer fizemos maior
melhor
fomos divertidos fizemos eventos memoráveis
o lentamente começamos a desap
recer  os clientes estavam escolhendo outros lugares
outros locais de entretenimento
lançamos uma campanha não para atrair
mais clientes, mas para saber como eles se sentem
por que  estavam nos deixando você não pode nem
imaginar o
que uma pesquisa nos disse as respostas eram
apenas surpreendentes
nossos clientes reclamaram que éramos muito
grandes
para moda para requintados para plástico
nossos clientes reclamaram que não
eles não se sentiam bem
então nossa força era nossa  pontos fracos
eu apresentei esses resultados para minha
diretoria e meu título de powerpoint era
síndrome de christopher columbus você sabe
porque
crossover marcou rumo para a índia e
voltou sem saber onde tinha sido
tão
tipo de mundo novo né
nossa visão de maior e melhor
nos impede de preencher  os nossos hóspedes
por isso é importante para nós que antes de
olharmos para o presente
e para o futuro tenhamos de nos perguntar
se realmente sabemos porque é que os nossos viajantes
nos escolhem
como se sentem o que
procuram nasci numa bela
ilha ensolarada  fria madera a propósito
a capital de madaris funchal casa
deste tedx
fanshawe fala e existe uma
pedra mágica verde e florida no
meio do atlântico é sp  tas
de viajantes desde o século XV a
madeira é agora notoriamente famosa
pelo local de nascimento de rodrigo
e christina ronaldo talvez já tenha
ouvido falar dele ele é um
jogador de futebol quando morava na
madeira sempre senti o quanto os turistas nos amavam
você sabe que
eles estavam sempre voltando meu  pais
amigos que eram turistas
sempre voltavam era uma festa
todos os anos
como todo mundo lá desse lado
na minha juventude eu estava tão ansioso para
sair do
meu lugar neste caso minha ilha e eu
queria descobrir o mundo então eu fiz isso
em uma idade muito jovem,
primeiro foi portugal continente reino unido frança
espanha brasil o nome dele
eu estava me sentindo marco polo surpreendentemente
eu comecei a querer voltar para aquela
ilha chata, ensolarada e verdejante no
meio do
atlântico quanto mais eu viajava, mais eu  queria
voltar
eu sei o que você está pensando claro
cara é a sua casa sim é a minha casa
mas o fato é que eu me senti como um
turista na minha ilha
todos os dias você se sente como  um turista na
sua própria
cidade mas existe a mesma
crise dramática
mas sabemos que os turistas vão voltar
eles sabem que há
nós sabemos que os terroristas vão procurar-
nos então o
que a Madeira está a fazer aqui
temos de voltar atrás  começou no
início do século 18
quando um médico famoso escreveu na
revista da sociedade real
citando tentando que além de uma incrível
beleza natural o
madero tivesse impacto terapêutico em todos os
viajantes para que os viajantes com
doenças da natureza se sentissem bem e curados
da doença que
você conhece e essa tendência continuou  e
com os líderes e influências inferiores que
chegam à ilha
do imperador sisi imperador charles da
austria
churchill migrator até o último rei da
nigéria tem direitos permanentes na ilha
sabes que perdi a conta de quantos
turistas sabia que estavam a regressar
à ilha  por mais de 20 anos
todos os anos e deixe-me contar um segredo
que descobrimos a ilha em dois
dias, então 20
30 até 45 anos como vemos
ah viajantes esta espécie maravilhosa que
nos traz sorrisos
perguntas estranhas roupas engraçadas e
prosperidade para o nosso país e as
pessoas quero dizer que não são difíceis de entender
você pode dividi-las em três
três categorias viajante de negócios
uma espécie ameaçada pelo seu tempo
derrotada pelo medo
orçamento e zona  chama viagens étnicas
movimentos migratórios que agora podem
aumentar com toda essa crise econômica
pessoas saindo para uma vida melhor
entrando
para ver os entes queridos e viagens de lazer
viajar por diversão e descobrir certo
não é errado você vê é claro que nós
viajamos para fazer negócios  gastar dinheiro
para estar com os entes queridos ou para se conectar
com pessoas e culturas
e em busca de um lugar natural bonito
mas
eu realmente preciso criar um suspense aqui
mas viajamos
onde nos sentimos felizes onde nos sentimos bem
para lugares onde sentimos isso  pertencemos
onde nos sentimos seguros onde nos sentimos
protegidos
muito poucos destinos inteligentes levaram isso
em consideração até agora
qual é a solução yo  você me pergunta simples,
você precisa entender o humano
por trás de cada viajante precisamos voltar
ao básico quando você pergunta a um viajante
o que ele gosta no seu destino
se não for um roteirista um jornalista
um político todos eles expressarão as
mesmas palavras
ótimo  filho diversão natureza comida aventura
compras e o que fazemos
nós investimos nessas palavras-chave são os
dados errados
estou baseado nos emirados árabes unidos um
país que enche o seu povo e os seus
viajantes como
muito poucas nações os emirados Árabes Unidos têm um ministério da
felicidade
uma nave espacial em  seu caminho para marte e
setor de turismo recuperação nuclear
e no meio da crise epidêmica
uma dessas cidades em expansão é dubai um
famoso destino de turismo global
formado há menos de duas décadas preenchido
por sua liderança veterinária e uma
grade impressionante para alcançar
enquanto trabalho na aviação  e turismo
dentro do
governo pude ver um grande esforço para coletar
dados
e entender se todos tiveram uma
ótima experiência
se todos fossem f  eeling happy
este enorme esforço este enorme
investimento foi feito para vender mais
produtos ou pagar por
influenciadores de mídia social a visão
é saber como os viajantes se sentem
como podemos torná-los mais felizes como podemos
exceder
e exceder e exceder a experiência baseada no mundo
como para  compre entendido há muito tempo
precisamos reconhecer que
destinos rápidos são como fast fashion
eles desaparecerão muito recentemente durante
a pandemia
um casal português que visitava em dubai
nos últimos 20 anos ficou famoso em
todo o mundo
antes de partir para dubai na
crise da pandemia no  crise epidêmica média
a senhora não se sentia bem ela foi
aconselhada a não viajar
pela família e médicos em portugal
ela compartilhou alguns anos atrás com as
famílias e médicos que seu marido
teve um ataque cardíaco no shopping
e estava tudo bem
nós  amo dubai é um lugar seguro tem
sido assim nos
próximos 20 anos será
assim então vamos de qualquer jeito
depois da chegada  l sua saúde se deteriorou
muito rapidamente
e ela foi levada às pressas para o hospital onde
estava ela foi operada
por causa de um tumor ela deixou o hospital três
dias depois
ela está bem ela está feliz aproveitando suas
férias
e sem saber ela se tornou outra
incrível embaixadora do turismo de dubai
é você  sentindo alguma analogia aqui a
madeira também começou a tratar bem os
visitantes há quase dois séculos a
sua natureza foi suficiente para fazer o truque
e depois geração após geração
após geração os habitantes locais aprenderam a
tolerar
e amar os viajantes fazendo-os sentir em
casa a
madeira e dubai têm muito mais  coisas
em comum
além dos jogos mundiais prêmios para sempre jovens
fogos de artifício
estão no negócio de fazer as
pessoas seguras e felizes
na comunidade tolerante que nos traz
segurança
ótima saúde e em última análise o
sentimento de pertencimento
este é o futuro do turismo
e o fato é que a maioria  dos
destinos em todo o mundo está mirando ou
sonhando
com segmentos mais altos de
viagens  ela porque eles têm mais
capacidade de gasto
isso vai gerar mais renda por
turista esse é o sonho de
todo material para este destino então para
desbloquear esse fluxo de viajantes de ouro eu
criei o turismo 5.0
porque nossos hóspedes estão chegando de
mercados mais próximos
com uma nova mentalidade que eles são
humanos preocupados com a pandemia
e a maioria já está doente
problemas cardíacos diabetes
pressão arterial problemas de mobilidade
desde os 30 anos
a mensagem deve ser muito clara estamos
todos aqui para você
você será cuidado turismo 5.0
é sobre entender o real
importância do turismo
investir em dados e não em anúncios do google
antes disso
precisamos saber como as pessoas realmente sentem
o que elas temem
o que elas sonham é sobre
líderes
e habitantes locais trabalhando juntos
com a mentalidade certa para proteger,
promover e entregar o melhor
experiência dos viajantes os
viajantes retribuirão investindo em
seu
país, pode ser um café no aeroporto ou uma
casa de um milhão de dólares não importa
porque um dia uma grande
experiência de café pode se tornar um cheque de um milhão de dólares
eu vi que o turismo 5.0 é sobre o
fortalecimento da confiança dos moradores de volta com um
plano
vamos fazer um plano para os próximos 10 20 30
anos
trata-se de melhorar os cuidados de saúde para os
viajantes e para os residentes
misturado com a sensação de segurança
tolerância e felicidade a sandes perfeita os
nossos turistas são humanos estão
mudados têm medo têm medo de
perder o dinheiro do bilhete
e o que acontecerá se forem apanhados
com  o vírus o que acontecerá se eles
ficarem doentes no seu país o
turismo 5.0 também é sobre a criação de
canais de viagem disruptivos, você não pode esperar que as companhias aéreas
que você não controla resolvam seu
problema,
elas estão muito ocupadas sobrevivendo, então
tudo bem se você não tiver  uma companhia aérea ao
seu serviço é hora de
resolver o assunto com as
próprias mãos e garantir que seus convidados
chegarão e não perderão o dinheiro
e são férias é sonho  ms
isso é fato um dos maiores cold fit
em futuras reservas
governos e cidades trabalhariam em
conjunto
com o comércio local para promover
pontes aéreas diretas para o mercado estabelecido
sim não é hora de ser selvagem aqui
vamos começar mirando nos mercados
que você já conhece
sim os viajantes que querem voltar
como fazer isso simples use qualquer
companhia aérea
que esteja disposta a alugar seus serviços
pense fora da caixa
novos canais de viagens disruptivos agora a hora é agora
não espere turismo 5.0
é a minha ideia de espalhar é  sobre
ser ousado e
pensar no futuro enquanto corrigimos
os
cinco vetores atuais que, uma vez implementados,
trarão mais confiança
e acelerarão sua recuperação econômica
o futuro começa hoje como você se sente
pode me sentir como posso ir lá
estarei seguro  você vai cuidar de mim
você